interdimensional portals have opened up
and enemies are pouring through time to
think strategically in Xiomara next big
update rush hold the events this update
debuts threshold defense at our defense
style mode reunion team of five hold the
line against the undead and Dominion
forces as they march towards world
domination take them out before they
reach the threshold by using your gun
wits and a host of environmental unlock
strategically placed throughout the map
killing enemies will earn you points
used to unlock turrets teleportal and
even a mobile mech suit that will crush
your enemies into a pole in addition to
threshold defense this update includes
five new Maps fresh out of the oven in
the new campaign sub-optimal infiltrate
and offshore submarine base and
eliminate enemy forces before they take
control of a fully armed nuclear sub
gay Green Mile rocks players in an
abandoned prison invested by the undead
on advanced and expert difficulties
watch out for the brutal and for
competitive play introducing three new
maps for you to whoop ass and take names
in financial ruin players faced off in a
once bustling financial district turned
warzone foul it out in power struggle a
mid-sized map set at the base of an
offshore nucular reactor and finally
no-man's land takes the fight to the
narrow alleyways of a war ravaged town
an arsenal eighty new weapons and a ton
of new gear blast their way into Cena
Marty keeping kicking ass and working
good while
five new assault in ck weapons at the
Armory as well as the debut of epic tier
weapons like the enemy piercing neutrino
rifle multi explosion Callister line and
an electrifying art cannon that's sure
to supercharge your existing loadout
this interdimensional update adds new
maps and a brand new mode so get ready
gear up and kill every thing